you did several voices right JB I did
yeah 33 yeah ok we'll we'll be able to
tell that they're all you or how did you
thought I hope not that I think the
trick was to try and pull off the fact
that it wasn't me so any of those sound
like you or they are also not usually no
Blanc Blanc characters that don't sound
anything like me anyway say that's I'm
quite used to that ok Maren you were
saying earlier that you didn't want this
to end so could you go into why um I
found Lily door so is the name of the
character and Billy dove plays it and
she's such a spectacular actress and
often one doesn't always get the
opportunity to have a role that is as
rich as this kind of role so I only got
to do a little bit of her but it I just
wanted to keep going and she has very
sensual scenes with who hey michau plays
and I don't get to work with Hamish
enough so I thought this is one way to
try it so David you I think consulted
with Laura Kennedy and Bernie on this
but played kind of the lead on this but
I'm just curious as to what was this
process for casting in this method and
how was it different than what you
normally do it's a particular challenge
to match the the light comedic touch and
the cadences of the actors of the day
and I knew that it was going to require
actors who were theatre trained who have
a really light committee touch fantastic
timing and also a very specific tabbert
to their voice and that was the the key
here I think is to try to find people
who you know could could reproduce these
very particular sounds and I don't know
there's something about the elephantine
memory of a casting director that led me
to remember specific performances of
each of these people and actually JB and
I had only had a meeting and 11
encounter but I've seen the work of all
three and it was easy to call it their
names i'm only thrilled that they were
available and able to do it and thank
you for doing so